it's the biggest crisis in Boeing's 103
year history on Monday after two fatal
crashes involving its 737 max jetliner
Boeing fired its CEO Dennis Muhlenberg
for breaching the public's trust the
Board of Directors decided that a change
in leadership was necessary to restore
confidence in the company moving forward
as it works to repair relationships with
regulators customers and all other
stakeholders 189 people died when a lion
air 737 max crashed in Indonesia in
October 2018 less than six months later
another 157 people were killed when an
Ethiopian Airlines jet also a 737 max
crashed in the north of that country the
u.s. government forced Boeing to ground
the check until problems with both the
operating software and with pilot
training could be fixed we've made
mistakes
we've learned and we are still learning
but despite repeated promises from
Muhlenberg to get the planes back in the
air by the end of this year the problems
continue regulators in the US and Europe
have refused to clear the 737 Max's
return to the skies and lawsuits are
pending lawsuit alleges that the lion
air crash was in part a result of
unreasonably dangerous conditions of
boeing 737 max air aircraft boeing has
lost more than eight billion dollars and
another 8,000 companies are also
suffering from lost business airlines
are scrambling to revise their business
plans and juggle flight schedules since
they don't want to use or buy jets with
a dodgy safety record and on friday
boeing had a setback in its space
business its star glider transport
shuttle suffered technical problems
forcing NASA to ditch a planned docking
with the International Space Station
the new CEO david calhoun takes charge
in january it's now up to him to
reassure everyone that boeing is taking
their faith in flying seriously Rosalyn
Jordan
jasira Washington Kyle Bailey is a
former member of the Federal Aviation
Administration that's the US
government's regulator
he says Dennis Muhlenberg the
resignation was months of a Jew
Dennis Muhlenberg the main issue I think
why he was let go is from his handling
of the the two unfortunate disasters
from that point after the public
relations the image of the company there
there was just no guidance and it quite
frankly it was a mess and I think that's
what ultimately led to the firing of mr.
wollenberg they're going in the right
direction
I'm a little bit surprised that an
outsider wasn't bought in but honestly
you know this is mr. mellenburg
departure is probably about three or
four months overdue and I think this is
a good the next step forward getting
somebody who knows the business and is
pretty much you know a new face who will
guide the company the way it should be
Boeing is a very technical operation
even even more so than in an airline
because there's sophisticated
engineering that that's actually taking
place and I think mr. calhoune with his
background in General Electric in the
Angeles Department I think he's the
right person from internally from Bali